all right so we are now post full day of
epic bball hangout interview with Josh
super fun we know have gal Shapiro
joining us on the set
Laurie's brother or he's on the set now
too so gal you have two stories and you
wanted to kick us off with yeah just two
stories from childhood PE that I'd like
to discuss so the first story is like
the PE teacher was dividing teams for
dodgeball or kickball or something like
that and he's like all the guys on one
side and all the gals on the other side
ha ha ha ha and he actually put me on
the team with the females as well so it
was like girls plus you boy against guys
and that was like how we did it
sometimes in PE it was like kind of a
running joke like guys and gals because
my name is Jo I got to play with the
girls team and then my second story my
second story involves basically I was
playing kickball and I was the pitcher
and one time a kid's shoe flew up in
there 30 feet and hit me in the head and
everybody was laughing and that hurt
like hell
and everybody in the whole PE class was
laughing and I just got hit by a shoe
that landed from 31 feet in there on my
head
well yeah ouch does anybody else have
any PE stories that like make it happen
like stories from PE I one of my son so
my son went to he tested to get into
this school you have to have like a
really high IQ use in second grade
so I come to pick him up one day and so
he's playing against he's playing
against the boys in his class so he's
playing one versus 11 in what in soccer
and soccer one versus 11 that's crazy
and he was holding his own he was just
like like all these kid oh he's really
smart
my son I still would just like playing
one on 11 Wow oh I have another have
another there's a interesting story so
you never do the egg toss even to us
like is like speaking of sensitivity
that works on sensitivity eggs like
sauce yeah oh yeah that's it right yeah
so I love doing that yeah look throw
your getcha this is like a company
picnic so I come and I go or we just
started the egg toss
so everyone so it's like I don't have a
part in anyone I want to do it no so say
okay I'll do it myself
so I I would throw it and then I would
run the get on the other side and catch
it interesting I throw it back you throw
high we throw it I run and I catch it it
produced a hard-boiled egg or what yeah
you know you start close and then you go
farther and farther apart there's about
10 people and sure is yourself have you
ever snapped 10 parents of people so
we're doing it and then it's down to
just 2 like me and this is your legal
into your sovereigns myself so it's like
this was king far away so I get the egg
and I throw it literal I threw is high
and as far as I could I just threw the
egg it's hard as [ __ ] and I just started
booking and I'm booking and I like get
by and I actually caught it I actually
like a landed in my hands he's bloated
broke but I got the man that was like
that was so fun it was about this great
it's a damp egg day the angel is so thin
I know but I mean it was fun
well how about how many feet can you egg
toss yourself yeah that was I don't know
it was a good question the world's self
make tossing chain there you go gal you
wanted to talk about basketball we had
an epic amount of
half-court games that we played against
some other peeps say you two actually
played in college gallon or yes play in
college yes Plato also you were
co-captain of well I actually play I
usually was that high school soccer you
said that's well inside this boat was
basketball yeah okay cool yeah yeah no I
averaged over 19 points a game for the
University of Connecticut are you
playing a con Wow Stanford branch Center
right Wow
still damn but that so that was your
average of 19 that's a gig well it was
it wasn't as good as high school I mean
the competition but anyway but but yeah
but I went to the the Stanford branch of
the University of Connecticut oh nice
yeah so anyway yeah and then you guys
also played in college and you guys are
both linked like for real fellows you
guys were like beast I mean you guys
both can dunk you guys both have
dribbles you guys I mean the true that
we both kind of rode the bench but we're
also talented we were also very talented
but oh I saw those reels I saw the reels
of you playing like that wasn't talented
yeah today playing with you yeah there's
thanks man yeah I'm a huge talent the
highest level I went was to try out for
the G League for the Santa Cruz warriors
and I'd tried out twice what did it make
it but that was my highest level but uh
Horry was the video coordinator for
basketball team on De Anza College so I
was in Texas and I was using my
headphones and training running and
practicing to try to walk on so I was
able to move to California walk on to
the team that Oriya was a part of first
as a video coordinator then as a player
and so or he took his talents to
Foothill College
shortly after yes and why did you want
to bring up basketball because bass
or ideas to it that are in many ways we
when we when we play or when other
people watch people playing or when
other people just hear the word
basketball or whatever sport it may be
actually sport has so many things that
are so deep into human into humanity
probably the deepest one is teamwork
another one is play another one is
having the set constraints these rules
of the balls like this and the point
system is like this you can't follow
people you have to dribble you can't
kick the ball right so there's all of
these rules that you play by and then
this is like you're literally running
iterations of how the games play out and
so there's there's so many core aspects
to sport that are easily overlooked and
we all played growing up of diverse
amount of sports and there's a main
massive part of our lives that what were
you thinking about when you said I want
to talk about basketball I want to talk
about basketball because basketball is
my favorite thing to talk about and if
I'm reading a book it's usually about
basketball
ever since we were kids my dad put my
brother and I in front of the TV to
watch basketball playing basketball we
love basketball and then we got a
basketball hoop in the driveway with the
crooked driveway so we would jump from
the high part to the low part and that's
how we were able to hire the hoop with
the crank every time a little bit little
increments dunk a tennis ball dunka
volleyball done good smaller basketball
and then you can dunk because the curb
lets you jump off from the higher part
of the driveway and that's the reason
Horry is what he is today and orey's
able to dunk like crazy and you got to
get infatuated with it and just love it
every day and we start posters in our
room of basketball players you know
filling the whole room you I'm like how
you talk about it from even from your
earliest parts of youth you
had the stimuli that we're starting to
inspire you and that you had to go
through this incremental process of
dunking a tennis ball than dunking
something a little bit bigger than a
little bit bigger until you could do it
all the way to the the football yeah and
it's you brought it up because it was a
core aspect of your life that's why yeah
definitely like whatever you think about
all the time will manifest so if that's
basketball and getting better at that
getting better every day at yourself
being the best version of yourself you
can be then that's what you think about
or whatever you think about will
manifest so whatever you focus on that's
what you'll reach right because your
thoughts form your habits and your
habits and your behavior forms your
character and then you are in pretty
much I just really love basketball and
then I think it's been a thing in my
family with our father being our coach
as kids and he took us to soccer first
and then basketball so we got the
footwork part out of the way oh yeah so
nothing would really bones with your dad
great way to bond with your dad is
playing sports being coached sports for
the Northwest YMCA Purple People eaters
something that
you think would be interesting to
mention just on this topic is as I was
talking about all these core nuances of
sport sport has been around for so long
and it's not just looking at the
modern-day sports and stadiums but this
is going all the way back to just being
able to discover what we could see what
we could do with even a simple ball what
we could do with simple games with
similar play and it's because it was
just such a core part of our development
and it's still today parents enlisting
children into sport and into music and
into all different types of activities
for the child to figure out what
inspires them and what gets them like
feeling like they're bringing their
gifts the world looking back at life
it's so easy to be able to like connect
dots and be like wow because I played
sport right did these activities because
my parents facilitated that for me that
I became Who I am today well I'm gonna
take another a different aspect of this
and talk about the play and sport
because what really stuck out for me
when you're describing today is that we
met these five people that we didn't
know never seen them before and you know
you said there's rules and everything
but but there aren't I mean we've made
up the rules we figured out what this I
mean what different rules I mean we sort
of changed the rules and but there's
always the yep my man likes to play
Tuesday 3:00 yeah I want to play two
degrees right my man wants to play good
even though it's not good for our team
he's like those say that
I get my twos and I want my twos I know
but see I like real basketball he's like
it's not stuff twos and threes of the
halfcourt in the half court
not in the full court if the half court
yeah and that's Louie loses out to
chosen through his losers out a twos and
threes 225 win by two and he says went
by for went by for my B's you playing
twos and threes 225 yeah Tuesday three
yeah and losers now usually usually what
else I'll go to a court and I'll say
here you can have the ball but play my
rules and I say twos and threes take
everything back and losers out and
happen or or full cap court half court I
do it all the time so there's rules like
you can't play twos and threes half
court you can no I know I'll play fives
half court I know right I know there's a
surge rules and we went against the
rules
see that but but that's what's so cool
is that that we did that with these guys
and but but that's such an intimate
thing like it their honor sports like
that there aren't sports where
I mean soccer can be sort of like that
at football obviously you know but the
basketball is such an intimate sport
where you're next to someone and you
know I generally have a closer
relationship I've got a positive here
for a second yeah just feeling like I
know I'm being quiet oh yeah and now I'm
being quiet quite just feeling like I'm
a little bit losing my connectedness
with us thank you
yeah man yeah you were thank you yeah
yeah I just like how human beings just
work it out like we didn't know these
guys and we worked it out and we're
playing like you know we're smashing
into people and doing all sorts of
things and it's not that clear what a
foul is or what a foul isn't and so we
have to work it out and there's just
such a you know I played basketball in
so many places with so many people and
it's just so cool that you just go
anywhere I mean if you just go to a
basketball court and show up there's
just it's just acknowledged that if you
make it you get the ball back right like
that's like it's just a cool thing it's
just like an unstated thing wherever you
go yeah it looks like that's what's true
and it just makes me feel good that I
can just show up with people and I have
a bond with them like we like me know
these rules and we come from this this
thing that we love right because we're
not getting paid to be out there we're
doing it because we love it right I love
how you said that you can just approach
yeah there's so many interesting aspects
that the way you were just saying though
one of them was that there's like you go
out no matter where you go you shoot it
you make it you get the ball back
there's also like you know you basically
the basketball rules in the Philippines
or in or in Japan or in Latvia or in the
United States are all mostly the same
unless there's little difference in my
little church one to two because every
scam play five on five half-court also
types of stuff and it's cool that you
can basically go and land in all these
different countries and be able to play
ball like this play a sport that's so
interesting and then the did when we
approach the court it was you know us
for approaching the court and sing okay
there's five other guys that are playing
there let's let's make the inquiry the
request can we let play for us with you
guys yeah and then like then we played
four or five but we love them it real
fast like you have to when you defend
people you are right here defending them
yeah and you get intimate with people
really quick yeah and you're dripping
sweat on to each other and and you are
um you know you have a sportsmanship is
critical it's not so Harry it's not
clear what a following yeah and so you
have to be you have to not try too much
to call like oh I'm being followed all
the time but you have to also be like
hey like that was a foul huh and like
you know we're cheering each other on
where you have to communicate you have
to be like you know there's a there's a
pic to your left that's coming so be
ready for that yeah you have to talk
about you
you know open passed me the ball all
these types of things and so these like
intricacies and nuances yeah they help
what you just drive actually was funny I
was giving I was giving a I was giving a
cup of compliments cuz I love it when
people do really well I'm just like dude
I was a great shot
yeah I'm like usually you only do that
for your team but I love also just being
like you have a good job two other guys
yeah was just like would you say no
opposed being congratulating or
something oh yeah yeah don't be a fan of
the opposition I learned that from Ori
in Israel I learned that from Ori cuz we
played with our cousins we each had a
cousin on our team and then the guy on
my team no the guy an orange team was
cheering for our team and or he's like
are you on my team where there's you're
cheering for them so or he didn't
appreciate that so I'm like don't cheer
for the other team cuz I heard always
say that well I'm an Ellen's camp cuz I
always always cheerful oh yeah I mean
like you can say good shot for sure yeah
sportsmanship yeah it's just it I'm
about what's what what's more fun for me
it's so much more fun for me both when
the other person is doing well and when
they're happy when we're I mean you know
and also a big thing difference is
whether someone if you're playing to
stay or not
that's huge plane to stay yeah stay on
the court yeah you win you stay yeah in
other words in other words competing
well no we were competing but you're
slowing are there people waiting to play
yeah when you're when you're yeah when
you're gonna have to sit your butt down
if you don't win that changes it
completely compare it you witnessed a
king of the court yeah I mean see we
were playing we didn't have to worry
about that so that makes it a lot that
makes it easier to do it just that
structure there was no team of five
waiting to play against the winners
right so we wouldn't have to not play if
we lost so see all that we did today was
half court and yet I'm tired as hell
yeah yeah likewise I'm gonna be
or and then it's a great exercise my
heart rate was body was thinking me and
my body's disorder and that's a gorgeous
thing to be able to move yourself like
that I didn't work out
yeah half-court it is so III I
participated something called the senior
the Senior Games of Senior Olympics so
that limpy's for people over 50
so there we age group 15 54 55 to 59 all
the way up so I was I was there hanging
out there there 80 year olds 82 84
others like group for that too yeah they
put I mean this is all over the country
this is this was just was that the when
Albuquerque but each state has it and
then there's a national thing I was just
the national you made it all know that I
mean I I won as an observer I didn't I
didn't I didn't try and qualify did the
top two teams for each state qualify to
go to the foot national it is cool the
point of that is is that it's it's three
on three and it's half court and it's
losers out but as soon as the baskets
made there's no check soon as the basket
made you throw it out past the foul line
and three-point line and then you've got
all fast
so yeah they play 12-minute running
halves and their scores in the 80s it's
crazy yeah it's so fast I think the
highest level of three-on-three in the
world is in the big three leak because
they use former NBA players one year
removed when Oh that'd be great yeah
yeah
303 it's a new Olympic sport coming in
oh good oh what 300 basses it just made
that today yeah yeah yeah yeah for this
upcoming three first time I mean three
is great however yeah interesting it's a
new Olympic sport I think it's halfway I
believe so futures oh yeah yeah yeah
June is yeah 300 well in Israel they
played three on three to seven by ones
and twos win by two but they call every
ticky-tack foul and a fade away if you
touch them like this if I win
yeah is made by IceCube cuz I guess he
has a big network with all these guys oh
the big three three-on-three League yeah
oh that we was
by ice yeah Ice Cube like runs it yeah
it's it's in its third season
interesting big thing is great they use
NBA players yeah they've got like who
like just some of them are like okay I'm
out of shape and but just and then some
of them are like damn like there's 50
year-old
Mahmud Abdul Rauf and he's like still
just like God is he's like this guy no
and he's he's performing yeah so that's
big three
they got 300 run it up he's holding a
basketball I like big three a lot I
tried to watch their highlights they're
in the playoffs right now and big three
started by Ice Cube I think it's in its
third or fourth season it's in the
playoffs right now you can watch the
sunday recaps from the week and it's
pretty cool yeah big three walks yeah
Allen what made you feel like asking my
brother to cow if he wanted to be on the
show hmm
leading up to today
it was becoming clear that we were going
to be having a blast today and also that
Ori becoming such a closer and closer
pillar of my life makes it so that
inevitably this the set the second the
second connection to gaol is now
becoming more and more gravitationally
important as well and so this being the
first time that we get to kick it you
know it was really important for me like
just wanting to have an excellent time
today and even Josh too because we have
been talking you up as well and like and
I'm just super pumped for that and then
the when you talked to me on the phone
for the first time you're like I can't
wait to see your North Star
yeah I'm like I'll see you bye what no I
really really I know what he's talking
about North Star what guides you in life
while you reach towards I get it but the
no one talks like that so just like
hearing Alan sake on on the phone for
the first time I was like you know this
is about to happen and then they got me
up in here in the simulation studios
where Ori works hard and guy just a boy
just got interviewed right here yeah it
was it was a it's a it's a big deal for
me to know you better and to be able to
have this beautiful interplay with each
other after a great day together to do
this and and creation is like the best
thing that like humans can do just be
using your creative energy towards
creating organic you know for people to
consume a different medium or United or
your sensitivity yeah
so incredible it's life-changing being
around you and your sensitivity it's a
life changing it's taught me so much and
it required a lot of work to be able to
become that sensitive mmm the way that
he helps other people also transform
it's just gorgeous she's very giving of
his energy abilities and his compassion
his empathy to people he'll just sit
there in old space and people will
unload on him innovate like I just went
to Starbucks and they said yada yada and
I know he's like uh so how did that make
you feel in oil just focus on them and I
can't think he excels even that example
is like such like you know it's like
like just a very tip of the iceberg
there's just like insane amounts of
human psyche that are not like you know
communicated in that in that example
there's just there's there's just so
much that actually occurs with the way
that Rory is able to skillfully hold
space for people to transform and and
there's just so many different variables
about what people are doing it's mostly
people are clearing their channels to
connect and anchor the divine within
themselves and it's just to to be able
to consciously hold a space where people
can do that is just it's it's a talent
that is currently super under the radar
like right now everyone's like become a
programmer and and people like what do
you mean a holding space like in the
future we're seeing it's like hmm you
know how fast can we teach in a
to write code well how fast can you
teach an AI to be able to dive to the
depths of the human psyche and help them
transform consciousness so it could
potentially even be something as insane
as people going to even school to learn
how to hold space human to human
interaction and also we hypothesize
engineering are like two of the biggest
futuristic jobs to have and so he's at
the edge like a decade before it's
really blowing up like that is what
happens when you constantly work on
diving deeper into the psyche like
you're like you have 15 tickets the
Warriors games this year yeah so you're
like you know 15 things the Warriors
games this year you know it's so pumped
right and like people get to choose
whatever look they want to spend their
time on period and like that's beautiful
that people get to do that and we get to
have such
great endeavors into our own interests
yet at the same time it's like this this
like first question about the ultimate
nature of reality when we're birthed
into the world it's like in a sense it's
like well there's so many things to like
entertain myself with or to or to pursue
that's why on the phone I'm like you
know super prompt to get into the North
Star so like I have this insatiable
desire to get into the depths of the
human psyche to understand the source
code of our reality to understand
people's North Stars to help people
unleash their gifts for that maximum
desires and I don't have as much of a
desire to watch television - I like
playing sport not so much going in
watching sport that much there's so many
things all of the all of being in social
media news feeds there's so many of
these examples and so you know people
get to pick their what they want to do
sometimes it feels like I don't even
think people know necessarily that
they're like wait understanding the
source code of reality understanding my
North Star understanding my gifts
bringing them forward understanding how
to connect the dices psyche but these
are options I didn't even know they were
options that's why I was doing all
entertainment stuff and so that's what
something that comes up for me is like
do people even know that they have those
options on the tool belt no they don't
I mean it's our birthright as far as I'm
concerned to understand life as deeply
as we can to understand ourselves and to
be this to be what our essence isn't to
express it like if that's not a
birthright to be yourself I don't know
what is and and to note and this is what
it just kills me to know what life is to
know about like I mean the idea that
we're debating evolution it's just like
it's just so insane but to know that we
come from this I mean that's the most
glorious thing but even but even to like
really know like how we're born I mean
you can just start there everyone can
agree that like the sperm goes into the
woman's egg and then these bodies like
how amazing is that
how absolutely amazing is that and yet
how many people actually get to
experience that the same level of
amazement that you have for how
incredible the piece of art is that is a
human body how many people consciously
have connected to that deeply yeah and
that that should be our birthright to
know what is to actually know it is and
not just what somebody's doing and who
they're
[ __ ] immunity sleep so if so then is
that then this grand dichotomy that we
have between letting like just being
totally cool with no judgment people get
to pick whatever they want to do with
their life you know yet
the content that we're distributing here
is trying to remind people that you have
other options of connecting to the
divine understanding this beautiful
piece of art that is the body unleashing
your gifts into the overall things you
so think so we said connecting the
source understanding our source code or
sending the things like so we're
consciously choosing to spread that
message so that then people can go hmm
maybe I didn't know those were options
or maybe I want
I knew they were options and I've done
it a little bit but I want to do more or
maybe they do it all the [ __ ] time
already and that they want to go and
endeavor into something else no yeah
this is surreal like I'm humble grateful
to be here and y'all like maybe food and
like you know I was a bit late so I may
have had my hands dirty but I got here
and then you know we were able to
achieve greatness playing basketball and
this guy's a interview classic one and
so whenever humans dwell together in
Union
you know such is how it is when meant
will make this because that first call
had that North Star inquiry plus glory
just brought up this gifts in North Star
inquiry lets endeavor into it if you're
interested
sure all right let's do it what would
you say is a North Star for you or what
would you say your gift sure you can I
mean my whole life my North Star was
three letters NBA you know but then you
have to get realistic and figure out how
to put food
the table so that's what I learned when
I started working at Jamba Juice when I
was 18 like you have to work but then I
realized I really miss basketball but
you can't be in two places at once
as much as you want to be CEO I mean
what's your Northstar I mean the highest
thing on the pyramid of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs is self-actualization
which is hard to achieve it's harder to
achieve the food and water right yo who
is the water there's right there
like survivals at the bottom I'm curious
what's it like for what's it like for
you guys to be with gal as he shares
with us
I you have such a natural childlike era
aura about you it's just very endearing
thank you and yeah I mean I'm just happy
like ever since I saw my dad passed away
at age 44 he was something like every
day is so valuable to have fun and enjoy
it you know and I love merging networks
and hanging out with a bunch of friends
so like my girlfriend's an introvert but
I'm an extrovert
you know like where is it at like where
was it at where is it at yeah that's a
great great question you know some of my
goals are just to be in good shape
to like you know have a good
relationship with my girlfriend move in
with her eventually get married start a
family have kids be independent from my
mom and independent from my girlfriend
like money-wise and things like that
nature and be in good shape
you know are some of my short term goals
so that's like my North Star for the
short term what is something that you
feel like you could wake up every day
and have deep meaning and doing um
that's a great question you know I mean
I am just in a new job right now I've
been working one month so like I'm
really happy that I have a full-time job
you know I was offered a couple jobs in
sports San Jose Earthquakes events
Golden State Warriors customer service
customer experience representative for
the new arena part-time and San
Francisco 49ers is a box office selling
tickets but I turned all those down and
I'm working at the Jewish Community
Center of San Francisco as a customer
service lead why did you pick that over
the
because it was full-time it's gonna be
really good I have benefits and it's
customer service which is exactly what I
was looking for and the Jewish Community
Center allows me to be around some
things I like there's a basketball gym
there on the third floor they have a
basketball court three full courts and
like there's a swimming pool people come
with their families and their mission
statement is like to bring people
together in communities together mm-hmm
yeah so it's a Jewish Community Center
but it's a misnomer that you have to be
Jewish to work out there sure yeah as in
this line you want anyone can go there
very inclusive and welcoming anyone can
be a part of the community center yeah
community center or the fitness center
yeah there's events that happen there
sure we have like lectures and stuff
yeah with really prominent people yeah
cuz flee from Red Hot Chili Peppers is
coming to talk about his book yeah and
Andre Iguodala it just came yeah Dean
would you want to pursue something in
like you listed the potential of what
the Warriors potential with the 49ers
like does it seem like yeah kind of
being like an MBA being this these three
letters that and was such a massive part
of your life like would you say that at
some point you're interested in doing
some sort of like deeper work in in
basketball and sure it's always been a
dream of mine to have that gal Shapira
basketball clinic and just kind of like
have like these two days and you give
the cheek kids like turkey and bologna
sandwiches or like Bologna and cheese
cuz that's what I like I like Bologna
and cheese and mayonnaise sandwiches
with Kraft singles and stuff like
Bologna which had pork I was eating pork
back then but uh you know really I would
like to give the kids two days to get
better at skill development conditioning
shooting dribbling passing because
that's what we did in the summer we
would go to summer camps and skill
development and you could learn a lot
from that so yeah I would still want to
be around basketball I love basketball
you know playing a little bit of college
and trying to
play professionally but it's holding you
back from doing the gal Shapira
like even the tiny like just take one
one kid or three kids and just do like a
two hours teaching session let's all you
back from like starting that um just a
potential conflict of interest with my
new job I have to check into it since
the JCC yeah because I'm just one month
they don't have to check you don't think
they may let you that way if you're on
the side like if you're doing it at the
center then that's different but if
you're doing it like at your near your
home in your running a business you
people can be entrepreneurs and also be
working at gal to me like you seem so
full of love you are loved like I think
there's so much like a radiant of love
thank you and you and when you talk
about your North Star and your gifts and
like what you care about brings in the
world that feels to me like most you and
that's and like just to be able to hear
you talk about it and like take steps in
this direction of like having a deeper
relationship with your girlfriend that
you love and a deeper relationship with
your work and the deeper relationship
with seen this future of potentially
doing a gal Shapiro with some young kids
school for basketball and stuff like
like that to me is like like this is
your gift is your North Star and like
the more you go in that direction even
incrementally or you brought up this
word you know functional like on a daily
basis being functional around these
things that matter to you most and just
being like really vigilant knowing like
what is driving your utmost like
functionality towards those gifts yeah I
mean I always talked about starting a
business I didn't know and what so the
most simple natural transition for me is
to make a clinical basketball because
that's what I'm passionate about so I
went to school at the new California
State University Monterey Bay and
Business Administration I got the
general degree because I wanted to be
able to choose which classes looked fun
so that's why I didn't major in
marketing or something like that
I wanted to take the classes that are
fun and I just got a Business
Administration degree and you know
learned some basic knowledge but people
like Ori are super super talented and
I'm just so proud of her
thanks go always hyper talented and he's
hyper sensitive hyper aware he's a
person who can really moment-to-moment
what's the word I'm looking for
moment to moment being present what's
the word for being present and slightly
for mindfulness or he can practice
mindfulness I thought being creation
it's like okay this North Star
basketball clinic those two words like
does your mom know that you know does
your girlfriend know no we're brothers
don't know no it does I mean it's not
far off gal has had he made like a
little podcast around the Warriors and
he got season tickets for the Warriors
for two three years going to be with him
and he fit fifth and yeah and he he
loves the water
and he would buy and sell tickets so
that that's a skill he would buy and
sell this season tickets and you Edition
about two friends why not talk to your
girlfriend to your mom to your brother's
it was basketball clear why don't talk
to more friends about it one of them
could literally be like you know I
already started like doing it with like
three kids like you want to come
help me on the days I can't do it like
you know what I mean there's three
things that could emerge from just
literally voicing it more into the world
like the new I agree I agree that's cool
I mean this is literally what I care
about is having other people be like
yeah yo that aspect my North Star
journey like that inspiration like I
brought it forth this and I was able to
achieve those next steps that's really
cool like there's so much brightness
that is like wanting to unleash itself
through all of us and like we have the
gifts and all of you have your gifts and
to unleash those fully into the world is
of the most important thing this yeah I
had so much fun playing basketball today
with you guys it was over [ __ ] four
that's it's a cool thing that you better
place the play yeah you're pretty good
with he's so good bro it's got a guy
it's fun yeah well I enjoyed how much
you enjoyed it I had a blast
yeah and Noorie was able to get loose
with his back all right at the beginning
hmm well it's Avedon there wasn't a back
issue Oh what oh yeah
I was able to have fun with you guys and
play a couple games and halia four or
five we lost for four
are we good at we could have got done
better but this but we were we were
moving like a unit yeah we were we were
we're assuming we're a zipping this
pocket bigoted zag we're zipping the
spots and moving like a unit and this
was the first time we played together
and we had we had a a togetherness
mm-hm and a natural sort of capacity
true yeah your boy over here is gonna
get a little rust cleaned off and then
he can be a better aspect to the unit
first year now you were sick with your
cutting and passing and dribbling on the
perimeter yeah except I have a lot of
important upgrades in my skills and that
domain to get to get better atmosphere
will pick a basketball later it's tough
and I were saying well we're and some
people choose to like I know basketball
something I love but I love listening to
like Jack Monty you on musk talked about
the future more and severe sure that you
know that so like I have like a hard
core like nose for like like sniffing
out people talking about the edge of our
world and like consuming that content to
refine my world sure so that I become a
better interlocutor on the show so that
I can then work on this grand synthesis
and all the stuff kind of stuff so like
that I put ads just a priority I like to
see Orion his play stay in his flow
State and I know he cares about
dominating athletically he typically me
when we play oh he beat you to what my
my my gal but my guy was watching I know
I was watching us play she's like oh my
god you couldn't believe it it's just
like I thought your friends is just like
beating on you oh yeah a physical player
doesn't give
day of the year it's like I'm coming
through you I don't get it yeah what's
your pit bull anyway I know there was
just so funny the reaction of my Calvin
sees what you're just like what she just
couldn't believe I'll tell the world
I'll tell the world guy beat me in
one-on-one 215 twice in a row and I was
trying my darndest yeah it's all the
world guy beat me in one-on-one or twice
in a row Josh silver at night guys my my
my basketball maybe the guys this
bicycle guy versus head I'm six foot
seven 280 pound guy and this guy's five
foot six hundred he's 511 180 hundred
and sixty hundred and sixty soaking wet
I loved listening to you guys in a sense
you were being like yo like you're being
like brothers that know that like you
can help inspire each other become more
ideal versions of your full potential
huge dynamic yeah and orey's like that
with everyone he wants to uplift
everyone and that's good right like if
you have in your mission statement I
want to help others and thank you man
information if your mission statement is
I want to help others yeah you know the
triple bottom line
Wow to have that comment come from two
or energetically come from two high
quality inspiring vessels and my beloved
brother is pretty sweet so so namaste
namaste devil stay followed with this
guy
should we wrap do you guys want to wrap
Oh freeze like that I meant like wrap
the thing up but then I realized that's
pretty stuff let's free salad bit right
hey Bill you dance millionaires world
peace
Oh track boys would be cool to have
viewers enter a topic and then we just
do a hole we can go see if anyone's
watching yo we want to see if you're
watching then you can enter a cut topic
for us to rip on so you can copy
regeneration of simulation into your
mind with stimulations filler really hot
now so I got a good rap tested to that
bro oh hush it up bro oh I know it sound
like a damn promo but he's my brother
and it's fair [ __ ] I see them stare but
it's all good cuz today we was getting
air yo me and Ori got the same colorway
grey shirt with the red pants looking
like some fire red ants just crawled up
just leaving bicha with that fire what
you want to sweet like dark chocolate is
good divert a spit like saliva Oh it'll
be the house that your boys on fire huh
I spit fire like a skateboard tire
skateboard wheel and I will and thrill
and kill and if I can track that a
[ __ ] millipede got a hundred
legs and you know I'm runnin man and you
see
on the court swishy like a [ __ ] three
[Music]
get it Alan being like a three yeah us
three yeah talking about our gifts how
to bring them forth yeah we fall doll
over on that Court
yeah unleashing that North Star
yeah it's not very far
yeah we know our divine path board yeah
it's gonna take a crash course but step
by step we get there all celebrating
bringing forth our gifts yeah unleashing
our gift yeah yo take it over yeah
what's the word significance
significance
[ __ ] man what rather significant I'm
miss the same I live it then you use the
word divine [ __ ] and we sweet like slime
maple leaf maple leaf going through a
transition and
make believe it's your guy let's take
your guy take it for a bit I don't do
much freestyling with them words I kind
of make more sounds
is what I've heard because I'm not
paying that much attention I'm just
letting it flow through let it flow
through yeah just what we go to go to
that's what we're gonna do or we're
gonna be
that's why don't we be instead of do yo
Allen gal and guy o are I you know we
are fly [ __ ] look we be Firefly with a
light on our but I don't know why just
because I love that thing be flying
around with a light around light in the
darkness alone darkness
yeah yeah here I go yeah I pull it to
the park run around like I'm on adderall
play basketball cuz my ass is tall bound
even pass at all play basketball my ass
is tall run like I'm on adderall cuz you
know mother [ __ ] backed against the
wall but I will keep fighting standing
tall cuz money look out but that'll be a
call do not pass him the ball make sure
that you [ __ ] hack him cuz he's gone
dude is [ __ ] six point six I'm like
dude I do not want to [ __ ] on my dick I
don't want to get my ass whooped on the
court that's my [ __ ] favorite sport
so I'm just trying to chill with these
dorks and just play as a unit as a team
like a poor I don't know
Oh
okay from a different be from a
different rhythm
this world is gorgeous
100 million species have lived on this
planet before or now there's 10 million
of them with us here there are 10
million species but nothing it's like
the human ever since the Adam and Eve I
can't fathom to believe what we see each
and every dawn and each and every Eve
finding even when I'm running in the
park in the dark can't you feel the air
outside and it's so pure going through
your lungs as I tell a story I'm running
laps on the track but I'll be right back
Laura at an example with my running what
you want to do are waking up the morning
stunning in the morning at dawn it's so
hot what you want to do but I'm taking a
sham stunning [ __ ] now that was really
cunning [ __ ] doubt you should make some
money while you do that [ __ ] out your
mouth is running freestyle flows the
days for oh and these people should we
need a sequel man that [ __ ] but we equal
let me pass the mic to my guy guy does
he fly fly and right before that we're
gonna do a transition okay
give me a word you don't want the rap
he's been doing something doing song
yeah no not just do I do more just beats
you know we could do for a little bit as
we could all four of us create a beat by
all taking on a different rhythm yeah
that might be something to practice off
camera I don't know
okay well it's actually quite easy like
what well we just do a beat you know
what we'll just do it let me just but I
feel like I'm getting tuned in like I'm
gonna get better and better our
freestyling if we continue this key but
someone can also go over this well I'm
gonna I'm gonna do more beats I'm just
gonna do my rhythm
[Music]
I'm not you okay
your word peace pinks in the streets in
the Middle East may have [ __ ] rise
like east on these beats I'm a beast
peace out we out got that [ __ ] [ __ ]
with the free staff yeah coming down and
I want peace of mind and I'm trying to
take every minute a time I need peace
rest on these beats rest in peace damn
look [ __ ] gal damn that was epic
would you sleep you sounded really
rested like you put on some bulletproof
vest and uh and you started just
shooting on them haters Restless oh yeah
how I'll be so fresh on the track a
breath mint while you new to the game
new to the game freshmen ah freshmen
yeah I got em forms of intelligence huh
yeah well I feel like I'm in permanent
kindergarten yeah universe is telling me
to tap into my hardened yeah that's the
place where the seed grows from right in
my heart yeah yeah
flower flower flowers flowers can't get
those flowers unless you water your
garden of your heart do not stop yeah
yeah look water water that garden of
your heart yo [ __ ] is like some art yo
and you know is getting really dank like
a fart whoo
and it's dark outside but it's light
[ __ ] that's our [ __ ] place all right
now let me pass the mic to my guy now
flip you're right talking about flowers
you reap what you sow so dumb season
they continue to grow
go go go go
[Music]
by the way I commented let's see for
those watching you guys have a single
word you'd like us to use as a freestyle
topic listed in the comments thanks for
watching everyone thanks for watching
everyone and thanks for watching
everyone thanks for watching everyone
yeah we appreciate you appreciate you
appreciate you hey
Auri on the track appreciate you
appreciate you appreciate a little thing
that you to appreciate you we appreciate
you
you yogi when I was look check check
check
yo we really really appreciate you but
we'd best Brit times unless you're
feeling really best a little but you put
together all the aggregate and we just
some dudes like Jesuit um I think it's
even better if you drive better if you
feeling like waking up and just fly all
into the skies and next that you wake up
like to the sky appreciation is great we
you yourself you have to become great
that means you unleashing your potential
unleashing fully fully out to everyone
everyone that you love even to the Sun
to the Sun above
gee the acronym son human earth thanks
to Josh silver for introducing us to bat
yeah put on your son cap going up the
son luck with your arm gun love it with
your heart
young growing up I am from acedia hello
haters but it's instrumental keep rising
that it's off like escalators yes
listen to this Brendon slow we
[Music]
appreciated to of viewers you know what
you mean to us [ __ ] some flam we've done
like run us brother best dunker in the
[ __ ] game NBA
I know y'all know his name look it's
really meaningful that have some viewers
care about one comes out our Spears our
mouths that's cute me word now how do
you feel
droppin the encourage new we appreciate
you
you
[Music]
appreciate you that was so beautiful
appreciate your new word love okay love
for the divine and that's the one up
above like I love I got nothing but pure
unadulterated unconditional love to the
one upstairs that's above to the man
upstairs that got love to the we're
pulling the strings behind the scenes
Pinocchio Inc on la Testament you go fly
you go see one day if you try we got
love for the man above window scrubs
we just got love yeah you heard him talk
about long what but where does love come
from what yeah love comes from the heart
yeah lovely singing is it art yeah you
got unleash that paint stroke yeah you
got a not being broke
you gotta dish it out you gotta throw
something bring that paint forth yeah
what color you gonna pick green orange
yellow red purple blue which color you
gonna pick how BIG's your paint you're
gonna be on the canvas of creation what
you're gonna do with your life how
[ __ ] hard you're gonna strive um [ __ ]
what are you gonna make of this give ah
as we breathe hug this life is your
existence you can take whatever you want
winded
can create and heal and grow and flower
[ __ ] right before an hour it's so
important to flower what else man
I'm just chillin what the hell don't put
me off the bench because it's game time
balling and wrapping the same thing at
the same time never a drop a lame right
hurry up this game time y'all still in
pre-season y'all think that we even on
the same level couldn't dig it with that
lame shovel that do [ __ ] a yielded
I'm dual yielding in Halo 2
mothersuckers as I freestyle yeah you
know sometimes it gets a little hectic
in wild while we still flow it like the
night dial talking about that [ __ ] and
y'all still in denial
damn oh yeah we got another topic thank
you for telling us in I assume re we
greatly appreciate you watch where you
go first
yo the topic is joy okay
and I assume re my name is Ari and let
me just thank you for your topic of joy
[ __ ] we gonna wrap it sweet like Chips
Ahoy whoo that's some cookies look joy
man that's a feeling that is an energy
that you can walk around with and just
wheel man you can just really just feel
it everywhere if you open to it or
choose it then your whole life becomes
some music and it gets really flowy like
some fluid and being Dao we grew up
Jewish but now we just open to the
spirituality that joy happiness a choice
yeah that good food and I like to really
really really have joy feeling really
happy even when some days make me feel
so crappy yeah I got that joy happiness
a choice and I'm eating good food you
don't say his pores and I got that
happiness when I'm feeling crappy news
and I got that joy his happiness a
choice
oh joy in our hearts joy in the heart
joy in creation Julian source alright
let's continue going to the next one -
what is joy to you everyone go around
and circle say a line what is joy day
we'll come back to you do it again love
you back waving from way over in
Tasmania
thank you for watching from Tasmania
greatly appreciated
guy what joy what is joy to you for
those that don't know Tasmania is an
Australian state it is on the south
coast of Australia yeah
just south of Melbourne yeah Tasmania
yeah vas rugged wilderness areas largely
protected within parks and reserves yeah
yeah maybe one day we'll go to Tasmania
maybe one day we'll bring simulation to
Australia that would bring us joy that
would bring us great joy
thank you for watching from Tasmania ok
one sentence at a time what does joy
mean to you
hey what joy joy is open to the
magnificence in every moment I think oh
man
opening to the magnificence in every
moment joy is opening your heart to what
is being okay with that be beaming
taking place whatever that might be
right joy is childlike innocent Bliss of
the being whoa
childlike innocent list of being things
like joy is like let's not be English
that is joy top light Athena since
places of lightness here I go I tried
like innocent bliss of be people are big
YouTube list they streaming here us on
the computer and childlike innocence and
they streaming people feel enjoy so you
know they be mean see me be me be me
yeah so you mom meant to Nevada Anaya
you said if you could see my smile you
have all brought me join your sharing we
said we appreciate you so much it's
making our evening talking to you what a
great topic that was talking to you
talking to you now you mean connection
across the world across the Sun too
costly something low talking to you in I
assume re thank you I assume re all
right let's do a new word that word
god that's blasphemous to use that word
bro in 2019 bro we're too smart for that
Allen God / source / creation / all that
ears / the truth / voice but I thought
about evolution that way evolution is
blasphemous to say it because that is
what that unlimited potential is what is
to need that the ultimate which is what
dies so to say that word evolution is
blasphemous because we have no idea what
it is to put it in a box and label it
recently I slept longer yeah and I don't
want to appear like some proselytizers
exclusive non-inclusive like come to
this like [ __ ] God is you God is what
you love God is what's inside God is
what makes you come alive God as home
inspires yeah thank you
yeah God so everything and goddess but I
mean to say God without goddess is also
blasphemy shiva and shakhty accessing
affinity forgot me
you know something that's been really
interesting about God we try to use
symbols to describe God yeah language
doesn't really work the best things that
work are you unleashing your inner
essence of God unleashing your inner
gifts of God yeah that is so God has
many differents that's it that's it's of
enlightenment you got love and infinity
and absolute twenty thousand more I
don't know the students been doing
spirituality from Momo
you talking 40 years plus [ __ ] dude got
the finger on his bow head by Muktananda
in 1960s [ __ ] are you with me why guys
see be good share the gift you see the
gift
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you bring us more so all
make sure this love enjoyed thank you
thank you bring us water so all may
share this love thank you thank you
Chris for all may share this
well
truth you can hear it in the message
thank you thank you
[Music]
yo think about this show and tie it to
it you got influencers right business
tech and science an entrepreneurship you
know I'm saying leaders in their fields
that's what simulations about and now
what is this that we're adding to the
mix what is it we're talking about
something specific but also not [ __ ]
yeah you know how I feel about what we
do but I have a clue sign spirituality
mixing together into a unity glue yeah
that will drive us forward that will
drive us to heaven that will drive us to
unleash our gifts unlock them together
yeah what do we know about life yeah I
know how to take those drives I know how
to unlock Oh strides and other people
yeah I know this you know we'll do a
good job yeah I'm proud of us we do it
together the big we w/e not I yeah it's
us it's us us we w/e not me not i yeah
not the ego not the ego it's the we go
baby we go on the everybody gotta play
their roles everybody play their role
everybody plays their role then we'll
get to the top like north pole is our
boy guy doing well I hope he can get
some guy you need some water I'm good
thank you all right back to that time to
the new everybody to play their role
then we climb to the top like the North
Pole huh leaders influencers artists
yeah what do you think man yeah what do
you think man like I'm the smartest
we got world's influencers and artists
huh Allen sake on Orion Shapiro the
heart is huh on this simulation see what
they them started huh episode 356,000
why you tuning in because they studied
while live haha island color tan Xia
ensnare Australia got damn near it's a
New Zealand looking like a Kiwi what you
wanna do you see me on the TV oh that
you to cuz I'm making new news it's the
Alan sake Laura Shapiro stimulation for
your ears relations for your brains huh
stimulation for you cuz you was going
insane and burying yourself but you
gotta get stimulation tune into the
simulation ah
that's that good affiliation rubbing
shoulders with the best in that nation
huh reincarnation and all of the sons
they talk about the subjects and they
just go a touch on olive oh yeah so 90s
in this nation
yeah the homies are going to other
nations uh yeah China's on the roadmap
in just a week I'm so pumped to
interview their leadership yeah
now next up is where we going next maybe
Saudi Arabia maybe Russia maybe Brazil
maybe Buenos Aires in Argentina there
are so many options people be seeing us
Alan got the universal network it ain't
even about net worth [ __ ] countries to
countries to leaders to influencers the
[ __ ] to spread the right stuff mmm unity
connection role community
[Music]
yeah collaboration each and every nation
across those nations collaboration
collaboration across nations
collaboration across nations yeah that's
a good tagline first simulation yeah
that's the vision huh I like that yeah
yeah yeah yeah on the tray last one guys
billionaires yeah kinda track
millionaires i'ma go and let my heart
shine empty everything that I can
until my tank is empty you feel me you
get me I'm on this track I feel like I'm
back in a studio and I'm gonna make the
most of it I'm with Allen suckin in my
bro so let's get it let's take the track
and rip it if you feelin great than with
us we all live here feel terrific Go Go
let's go the track and riff it run the
jump or hop like a frog like really big
leap onto a higher timeline yo dis a
grand opening who got the ribbon cuz I
just brought my okay here's how I feel
how you feel very even keel yeah yeah I
feel even keel that's how I feel I know
that if I feel then I can unlock
sensitivity in my essence yeah bring
that message forward to the world let it
unfurl let it on the world let it tell
its story
yeah each of us are unique so let inhale
our story our story
my name is Ori and we're here for you
guys a story
we're here to feature all these leaders
in their stores no matter who you are no
matter what your art we just want to
capture that gem that you are wanna
feature your stories my name is Ori his
name is Alan and Galland I'm Lori like a
[ __ ] said from the beginning to the
end
what's up to the world y'all are not my
friends Alex our kids and that boy or
disappear I did again video of that play
simulation then you know we do it from
beginning today good what I just said
being to the end beginning to the end
okay let's be real everyone we all live
on the same planet all 100-plus billion
people before us help build civilization
it's time for us to be more grateful
let's do it it's time for us to be more
collaborative yeah it's more inclusive
no matter who you are or who they are do
your thing and have room for their thing
yeah and support each other
there's things support each of their
stories so then everybody becomes a
leader of themselves and their path and
their blueprint everybody becomes a king
or a queen of themselves yes and crowns
are their people so they don't go to
hell because hell is just unfulfilled
potential that's what hell is
it's unfulfilled potential tom everybody
meets the [ __ ] flower for us to make
this world a better place in our final
hour um let's take a shower let's make
it rain in this bliss of co-creating and
[ __ ]
love quotient L Q remember that embodied
that let it fill your soul fill your
spirit yeah collaborating rough day was
the last song I just wish that this
thing would just last long
get killed like the last song and you
know y'all wish that it would last long
uh whoo
fire fire fire guys guy come over your
job good job same live I let's close the
show
that's cold let's close the show let's
close the show let's go show ok we're on
to him I don't know what we're doing
we're gonna do a hug we're seeing
goodbye we're wrapping up and just
packaging this gift I wanted to come
through that was so fun what an
incredible convo between us and free
style and depth into the psyche love you
guys very much and thank you everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking
I have no conversations to your friends
families co-workers people online about
the topics that we discuss in this
episode share more of that inspiration
around the world unlock your gifts bring
them forward commune with the divine we
love you very much
please also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the organization's of
spiritual leaders around the world that
you believe in support simulation our
links are below to our paypal patreon
cryptocurrency you can find another link
to a design cool merchant pay and all of
us think you pay for all that cool
stuffs below go and build the future
everyone will NFS your dreams into the
world we love you very much thanks for
tuning in yeah we will see you soon